what's up everyone wearing a cowboy hat
and boots be careful dear Rach I can do
anything
you got your perspective what up
Instagram good morning good morning good
morning I am in Napa Valley and I am
working on the GB wine project GB wine
project calm I highly recommend that you
go to that website right now or that
Instagram and sign up the GV wine
project calm so what is it at GB wine
project really this is just about
beverage
you know like my leverage of like
facilities getting a better deal
grapes getting a better deal working on
less margin it's not super complicated I
think a lot of times people think you
know the way I've built businesses that
I call yourself you know a lot of you're
so smart you did so fast how'd the wine
library go so fast had a later media
grow so fast it comes with giving people
more like you know it's it's just like I
take less I give you more
[Music]
to maximize impact my thesis on this is
is really simple free and lack of
friction meaning you know I tell
everybody don't charge for content and
then don't make a make it that they have
to consume it your way I think you
should be creating scenarios that create
content I'd be putting yourself in
physical positions that create content
let me give you a concept to a show that
will destroy you call it brainstorm
breakfast right we're like you just get
three four five people you're given a
little like little awareness and really
it's a selfish act because again you
jamming as a mentor and four or five
people shooting the [ __ ] I promise you
this there's a one-minute clip in every
breakfast that is going to be the
breakout piece of content for you on
Instagram the lack of content Tom comes
down to judgment and insecurities it
really does and here's the biggest thing
brother and I'm saying this for myself
too you and I are gonna be really
[ __ ] sad when instagrams algorithm
collapses the way Facebook's did and it
can happen any day and then we're all
gonna look at each other and be like
mother [ __ ] when I had the chance to
post four times a day and get 30 40 50
percent organic and now I only get 2%
I'm a [ __ ]
[Music]
good how are you pleasure are you
partner good good all right yes yes yes
all right I'm in the game like it is
those listen man nice shoes off this is
fun look at those song you like that you
hate that I'm in the game now guys it's
very real I think so too
beautiful this was a mistake of you I'm
wearing it I'm in the game
be careful dear Rach I can do anything
it's the first time I've ever wore combo
before thousand dollars I mean I think I
can get physically tired of times when
it's really crazy
but not mentally I'm too grateful to be
tired
I also countable I also think I'm
accountable I feel like if I'm tired
well I made that schedule I'm in control
so like I try to like like I'll do
things to make myself less tired if I'm
feeling that I'm getting tired I just
hate people like I'm tired yeah you know
I'm like Louie phrase I'm in control of
my life in so many ways that like I
don't have the right to say I'm tired oh
he's ready to rock
I started seeing you know people in
college you know gravitate to the idea
of like people who were the laziest you
know kind of would never go out of their
way to do anything would literally you
know go to the library and wait in line
to go on this internet thing it just
made so much sense to me that that
technology was gonna matter today do it
what do you do with that you can look at
this is like your free abstraction look
at it and then depending on if anyone
owes a pen or a gel
the magic so this is your starting
gradient for everything this is basic
this is the number one revenue
generating brand in all California last
year and that's a kind of more on the
red side this is on the medical side we
have a chocolate line lease on there and
then this is just launched this is a so
online receiver they make any getting
into the sets this product here so
basically free license that from that
guy yes yeah I do not so we made it for
it to be childproof
but in the end it ended up being
receivable as well it was like was it
even actual purpose but back in the
fridge string huh and hold all the
carbonation interesting I'm just getting
going the like I'm not I'm not like I'm
not cliche I'm not blown away that it's
so professional great I mean special do
you think about like you know this
better than I do like but I've been
around the block enough like first time
shows are not no joke you know like
building from this base like the growth
is exponential yeah so it looks great
I'm excited about talking a little bit
like humongous you see the first one is
like trying to build audience yeah the
first one's like a little does it
doesn't feel like this yeah yeah so okay
the rats first of all some brand here is
gonna make the number one podcast in
this space like I think I think this
space has to think like a media company
not like an advertiser okay got it
become the platform not be beholden to
it and so if you think like a digital
marketer you're [ __ ] because Google
and Facebook are the market and we can't
do [ __ ] if you think wait a minute I'm
gonna write white papers and put them on
LinkedIn I'm gonna start a podcast I'm
gonna do a daily blog not experiential
they're killing already for sure and
that's like a mock right like like I
feel like when I hear that pedigree I
don't even need to go there they don't
need to pay us or anybody else for that
it's right it can always be better but
he knows that's quarter producing a
podcast or doing influencer marketing of
like eighty seven hundred you know or
you know suburban High Net Worth moms in
California given the snaps that's
different so this is the first booth
we're debuting in year already people
who's in there
amazing good worked on this three-year
and I
do some big things together somewhere
[Music]
yeah I got I got a pleasure before this
mock-up in Telugu billion possible
couple other companies like
thank you so much thank you cats for the
emerald-cut sup yeah yeah are you
familiar with the brand no not yet
cannabis brand you should I figured that
would be a yeah got about 30,000 people
here every December good for you yeah
yeah it's been passing up if we were
working together send me an email and
cannabis that me me mailman love to talk
he's gonna build one of the biggest
distribution companies coming from
alcohol into the cannabis space if not
already but crushing it see you again
yes you connected
the guys doing the news starts with an A
one word
the Bill Maher's coming yet young
people's attention ATT annex yeah so
glad right now I feel so good wrapped in
a little Kate I guess good to see him
when did you guys get involved I joined
in January I saw what President you sold
out sold out of beach whiskey American
harvest yep
and my wife said I need for you man yeah
of course she's like putting Indian were
you doing at a liquor deal we got a look
at this canvas thing okay I don't know
anybody but I'm gonna so I went through
like ypl we ended up I got a dinner with
my 35 YP hours and I snapped between
Todd Kaplan and Courtney my partner's
now and I like that he was health care
see this food and I'm like I'm smoke I'm
from the liquor business I'm just here
to learn and like we need you we're
gonna do distribution and brands so it
was just like it was a natural fit
there was only once I talked to so it's
great to see a man of it helped on the
rendezvous game
oh yeah a pleasure yes guys have been
riding hard with this hey guys how are
you I follow you I follow you a mystery
man cool New Yorkers now that's already
good that's right
and we're really going heavy in the
subsidies and off machine sitting on the
whole thing yeah so really like
international distribution facilities
and the Frog and Europe and you know
South America all this stuff but really
really really going forward harder than
anyone else that we know and screen web
app yep now we're putting in
dispensaries so that customers can come
in and order all of our ancillary
products a lot of the dispensaries they
just have shelf sweetie now is probably
understand people go and they buy oil
charlie
commercially costly put them in there
for break we're cover of course she did
yeah if I see you again
when I think back up tech and that's
really the one the people that were
building the next big startup the amount
of homies that I have that were offered
to be number seven number nine number
fifteen at Facebook and uber but didn't
go because they were building schmooper
they [ __ ] up there's a lot of you in
here right now who have a business that
has no [ __ ] shot you think it does
you're excited meanwhile the person is
literally sitting right next to you is
about to build a billion-dollar CPG
brand your homies she's killing it and
grows in about four months she's gonna
hit you up and be like yo you want to
come and join my [ __ ] and be this and
you're gonna say no because you got
[ __ ] ego and you think schmooper is
still gonna make it
and then in six years you're gonna come
up to me be like yo you gave this talk
at this conference and the whole
schmooper thing yeah that was me I
[ __ ] held on to schmooper number 17 at
her startup made 44 trillion dollars and
I [ __ ] work at Bank of America
yeah it's called nobody gives a [ __ ]
about my feelings
[Applause]
I appreciate it I'll tell you why it's
an important mantra we are living
through right now especially in America
look I don't want to get like super
macro here but here's what happened we
should be just getting out of a
depression or a massive recession we and
this is not political on the back of the
Democrats and the Republicans we as
Americans in 2009 didn't have the
appetite to eat [ __ ]
so we bailed the whole thing out we are
in the most ludicrous generation of
entitlement of all time and this isn't
the kids the [ __ ] parents are the
ones that raise these [ __ ] kids this
is the parents and the kids and the
grandparents we have lived through
abundance and growth and Easy Street for
a long [ __ ] time of course not all of
us some circumstances we got plenty
issues but in the [ __ ] macro so the
reason I'm always happy every morning
and my mantra works for me is the only
people in the world that listen to you
complain are other [ __ ] losers and
your mom and so I navigate happy because
I'm just grateful for what I have then
other people have more other people less
when I had a whole lot less I was happy
with the [ __ ] I had and I just every day
recognize that if I'm in my own head and
realize that everybody's got their own
[ __ ] too then I don't spend time
complaining and dwelling I spend time on
doing
I'll never be able to replicate the
feeling of like new beginnings you know
and this feels like one I was really
excited about that keynote and I think a
lot of you I think I'll be good one I
think it'll be keynote that's analyzed
for a long time I really do for a lot of
different reasons
so want to put on film and say when it
does get analyzed in 30 years
I knew I'll be like I knew it was gonna
be analyzed see it
[Music]